[Musik]
die soll aber dass ich im südpunkt vom
tod und geruhsamer schwerer gang
und das ist umso richtiger beruf oft und
wie es wichtig dort begangen auf die art
wie du noch klappt wird ohne dass
kräuter hat große angst sie von dort
wieder momente mit einem tollen match
gegangen sondern mit freude ja stark
showbusiness immer sehr interessant
praktisch war einfach so dass ich
einfach wie nur möglich zu stark war
jedoch doppelt stirbt
[Musik]
wie geht das sich das leben nehmen und
es nicht mehr loslassen
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
mit christoph trummer kann man das
staunen wieder lernen mit 60 jahren ist
die welt immer noch ein wunderland für
ihn dass ich so jung oder alt hier das
ist das ist schönstes stück über das
schönste stück tantal roma hat sich vor
25 jahren entschieden während der
sommermonate im bach bei der ängstlichen
im berner oberland in die natur
hineinzuwachsen
hier ist doch standard erreicht tag
standen
alle
wie nie
[Musik]
mit schwemmholz steinen lehm und kuhmist
hat er sich in jahrelanger arbeit ein
refugium geschaffen sei ein ort des
einfachen lebens und hohen denkens
gewesen sagt römer
bis der fluss im vergangenen sommer
alles vor gerissen hat alles außer einer
kleinen hütte an erhöhter lage
[Musik]
folgt das volk aber das was jetzt
untergeht habe es aber an andere hatten
besuch stark es bin ich gespannt was
etwas über durch standard kann man
häufig sowie abstand
[Musik]
bis klar ist was genau auf stehen wird
kann es nicht schaden sich hinzulegen
allerdings nicht um nichts zu tun
druck auf die nasa auf tour
ich spüre auf tour und das ist immer
könnte sagen so glücklich vorstand und
ja bis zu beanspruchen ist frieda
[Musik]
drum hat sich entschlossen nichts zu
haben keine arbeit und kein geld nichts
außer zeit aber dass sich unsere
leistungsgesellschaft muss man
eigentlich sagen sind jährliche triumph
versagt sie an sony bruch matthias
sammer gesunden körper was was ist wenn
man wald gewonnen hätte zell verloren
lieber zu gewinnen und wald verliere man
kann seinen wolkigen duktus belächeln
ich möchte etwas anderes nämlich
versuchen zu lernen wie man es schafft
dass einen die schwerkraft des lebens
nicht aus nicht nicht dass in der alltag
nicht auch mit banalitäten behelligen
würde etwa damit dass es zeit wird sich
um feuerholz zu kümmern
trummer hat eine ladung bei seiner
mutter zwischengelagert er muss es nur
noch nach hause transportieren und
hacken
wenn es kalt wird sieht jeweils vom
bachbett in ein kleines häuschen am
rande von frutigen
seine winter verbringt er nicht allein
sondern in wohngemeinschaft mit judith
rott wie würden sie denn in die bezirks
so beschrieben platonisch wenn man dann
ist erscheint sie wie briten ja genau
und das ist viel einfacher als
verheiratet wieso muss einfach einfach
was immer man kann also sage ich jetzt
gar nicht ihm ist ähnlich vor 30 jahren
waren die beiden kurz ein paar aus liebe
wurde baut freundschaft
drum man hat nichts anbrennen lassen
er ist vegetarier war der fleischeslust
aber nie abgeneigt die frauen mögen ihn
auch wegen seiner kochkünste eine
familie gründen mit den dazu gehörenden
verpflichtungen das wäre für ihn aber
nie in frage gekommen
ein kostverächter zeit deswegen noch
lange nicht gewesen sagt er aber
gleichwohl eremit so einen richtigen
eremit zins jahreskarte und der
mitbewohnerin erinnere mit was heißt das
dass er ist im hartz iv zu ändern wäre
mittag
es geht um klappt ich ständig um klappt
es und in die sich des lebens um die
ende um die innere sich des lebens und
wird geht es mitte ziehen
[Musik]
trummer hatte zwölf jahre lang eine
freundin seine große liebe
es endete unschön jetzt ist er
enttäuscht und wieder allein
[Musik]
viele sagen drum muss sie finden seinen
lebensentwurf interessant aber seinem
beispiel folgen das dann lieber doch
nicht
[Musik]
das ist mein geschäft wie aus stein und
in st
ja klar das leben ist demnach also unter
mithilfe mega so offen abidal in segovia
flucht sie also kinder generell mit kent
kinder womit auf dem pfad so einfach ist
aber bewusst verzichtet
[Musik]
drum hat das nach seiner lehre als
elektriker in die welt hinaus gezogen um
nichts weniger aus dem sinn des lebens
zu finden
zuerst ging er nach italien griechenland
und israel
dann nach indien wo ihm alle sachen
gestohlen wurden
er meldete sich nicht bei der schweizer
botschaft sondern lebt die monatelang
auf der straße und war danach ein
anderer als er alles materielle verloren
hatte merkte er dass er dadurch etwas
gewonnen hatte freiheit
[Musik]
die frau rief existenzangst wie vor 24
stunden am tag offen panamahut wurscht
niemand ist da der chocri sehnsucht nach
irgendwann einfach frisch mit dir mit
die mit dir zusammen mit dem harz
unterwegs
[Musik]
das verhältnis zu seiner mutter war
nicht immer einfach
inzwischen aber habe er seinen frieden
mit seiner vergangenheit geschlossen
auch mit seiner unglücklichen jugendzeit
wie siegfried gesät dass die bibel sich
der letzte ball so dass ich sie da sie
ja das ist klar
das ging fix sie aber einfach nur den
aktiven für die gesperrt werden
krumme stammt das eine revanche italien
arbeiterfamilie
er war das fünfte von sieben kindern
er schloss seinen eltern zuliebe eine
lehre ab und machte die rs dann brach er
aus bis nach indien und als er von da
zurück kehrte war aus dem lieben buben
ein junger mann geworden denn seine
familie kaum mehr wieder erkannt
[Musik]
das gebäck ja böse kräfte gewesen als
uploader seit heute einfach festhalten
gleichwohl ich brauche die nato versteht
was ist dass die studenten gar nicht
merkten was ios gerät noch heftiger
moment denn mitunter gar nicht da sind
ich bin schon verschiedene wie ich dir
warum durch besuche oder journalistisch
so ist ist verschwunden
also wenn ihr nicht die gruppe hätte
kaum über jeden kaputt
ja da empfindet aus versehen
trummer sieht sich auf einer mission er
will der schweiz zeigen dass der weg zum
glück nicht über mehr sondern über
weniger materielles führe und über dem
konsum von hanf diese pflanze sei eine
art baum der erkenntnis hatten im
indischen sogenanntes autos nämlich
erklärt also jetzt aber die zu sich
nimmt wird zur großer innerer
erkenntnisse zwangs mäßig so was wieder
kenntnis sind sieht ein co ich bin zu
der erkenntnis dass das mir sehr gut
dass das mit dass das mir weiter bringt
dass das mitunter bewusst sie muss
sichtbar macht dass ich aus raab peter
und und anna und und und aber das war im
dunkeln liegt dass das jetzt licht und
die polizei zeigt auf ihr wenig
verständnis sie büßten jeweils er zahlt
die busse nicht wird deshalb verhaftet
und muss ein oder zwei tage ins
gefängnis
nächstens ist es wieder soweit das mag
das schloss ist machtmissbrauch und und
da und nach
[Applaus]
bis der halter netto der historische
verlobt und vitamine vitamin d liegt am
hagen losert elektro nie da jetzt
gefangen ist so die haltung und muss mal
im sinn
jetzt fangen ist der kleinkrieg mit den
berner behörden ist ferner noch lange
kein grund seinen täglichen hanf konsum
zu überdenken
ein paar tiefe züge genügten sagte und
der geist schwingen sie sich in luftige
höhen empor und es sei als blicke man
durch ein mystisches auge
[Musik]
zu den mystischen inneren mystischen
auge schaut die mutter als vermisst ich
ja jeder gras haben alles ist es ist
göttlich natur einfach mystischer natur
[Musik]
er umriss handwerklich begabt seine
dienste sind in und um frutigen gefragt
er hat dem staat deshalb noch nie auf
der tasche gelegen
er arbeitet allerdings nur so viel dass
er seine 700 franken fixkosten krummen
abdecken kann und nicht nur aufträge an
bier sinnvoll findet so schlimme tat
geht das einfacher aber federhofer alte
lied spezialfirma calw und so das macht
sinn und wie gut dass ich mich einfach
bescheiden aber finanziell krumm machen
unterstrich wien im jahr deshalb
verständlich camille des tvb aber nicht
in dem sinn also mehrwert stückzahlen
mirago vierte bradley und der vierten
minute und als damit seine fans steht
die commons stuhl muss man sehr stolz
auf dieses existenzminimum abusir dass
man mehr verdient würde dass man braucht
da schon richtig das was richtig
versteht wird
[Musik]
er sei verhaftet worden teilt mir seine
mitbewohnerin an einem freitagmorgen mit
die polizei habe ihn in handschellen
gelegt noch bevor er sich an seinem ofen
habe festketten können
da fiel mir die religion muss hierbei
einfach verfolgung vor religiöser
minderheiten und st
das handwerk sowie für das ist wie im
arbeitsmarkt ich finde jetzt an also
nicht nur noch ein mädel für ganze
religionsgruppe heute sehen wir das
sakrament man darf sich fragen ob es
verhältnismäßig ist einen 60 jährigen
kiefer wegen zwei hanfpflanzen zu
überwältigen und in hand und fußfesseln
wegzutragen roma fühlt sich gedemütigt
und denkt nun ernsthaft darüber nach bei
der nächsten verhaftung die
handgreifliche konfrontation zu suchen
[Musik]
woran sie tatsächlich würde waldrand
würden sie doch nicht in fundamentaler
widerspruch mit der lebensphilosophie
aber das geht es vorsieht
die gewalt lasse sie mit mit der
qualität für praktika kampf ich starte
mit gewalt nicht mit gewalt ist wie
dieses quartett war zum start griff zu
und abschaltung machen die haltung dass
sie schaut der konsequenz dass wir viele
teams die das apple logo für
hanfpflanzen das gerät und anpflanzen es
geht um gerechtigkeit und wahrheit und
kräftig wie das gelände machen
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen wird um entlassen von
schwertern und ähnlichem ist heute auf
dem heimweg nach frutigen bereits keine
rede mehr
das mittel verbraucht
zornig nachlieferung platz machen wie es
weitergeht
der kampf um viel geld
einerseits will er nun die
öffentlichkeit sensibilisieren bevor er
verhaftet worden war hatte er darum
bereits zwei plakate aufgehängt
[Musik]
im übrigen kann es nicht schaden über
alles weitere zu es noch einmal in ruhe
nachzudenken
[Musik]